first of all a quick question on the
energy price Rises the government has
introduced its support package which
will shield people from its worst
effects won't it and their package is
going to be there to support people over
the course of two years just does labor
now stop and think that they should have
committed to a bigger package that
you're only offering support for six
months won't you
well firstly it's good to join you this
morning and just to say that the labor
party argued for the energy price freeze
it is a one positive that back in the
early part of September the government
did follow where Labor led and finally
introduced a freeze what we did very
responsibly back in August was to cost
out the price of our freeze until the
end of this particular Financial year
but we were also clear that there would
be longer-term support as well and we
have also set out how we would create
not just that energy security but that
long-term stability in Energy prices we
announced at our party conference Not
only would there be the the insulation
of 19 million homes I'm astonished the
government hasn't done it already over
the past 12 years but also Great British
energy a publicly owned company that
will now be able to drive forward the
increases in Renewables that we need to
see the doubling of onshore wind the
traveling of solar the quadrupling of
offshore wind that is what the focus
should be the immediate help that we've
argued for but also that long-term
stability that our economy and our
energy Market needs and that our people
and businesses need but I'm afraid has
been put so at risk by this government's
Reckless approach the economy with a its
recent budget
what do you say it's a reckless approach
to the economy we have had the Prime
Minister Liz trust today uh
acknowledging there had been some
disruption in the aftermath of the mini
budget but she said that they had a good
plan for growth and we need to give it
time essentially meanwhile the
chancellor has also
um written in the Daily Telegraph today
talking about
saying that November's statement will
include a credible plan to get public
finances back on track talking about
commitment to spending discipline
do you feel that the government has now
tied everything up has answered a lot of
the questions around the mini budget no
absolutely not and even in even in that
answer they seem to be saying we have a
plan but we're not going to share with
you for two months they're in I'm afraid
a a dreadful position this is a Tory
crisis made in Downing Street and
working people are going to pay the
price and they've crashed the economy by
handing out enormous unfunded tax cuts
to the very wealthiest people and it's
going to be working people across the
country who pay the price of this
they've also trashed our International
reputation the IMF for example
expressing concerns about the
government's plans uh the former
Governor of the bank of England
expressing concern about this
government's undermining of our
financial institutions and I'm afraid
what the government has done is going to
lead to economic pain for people that
they have chosen whether it's the higher
prices the higher mortgage we've already
been here have been heared about so the
government what the government needs to
do is recall Parliament and withdraw
this budget
what about the obr forecast
um as you as you hinted there they will
now come out at the end of November this
is the independent Watchdog that
assesses at budgets will labor try and
get that published earlier I understand
that there's an arcade parliamentary
device called a humble address will you
use that to try to get that published
sooner than the end of November well we
will work uh across uh parties at what
may be the best way to put pressure on
the government to actually publish that
but just think carefully about what
we're saying here we we would be
pressing for the government to publish
something that previous governments have
simply published and as a matter of
course the obr's independent assessment
of uh these of budgets has been has
become a central part of what we do and
the government is running away from it
we talk about opposition parties needing
to use devices to force this but the
question is what on Earth is the
government afraid of the government
could actually publish it and if they
did that and it contained uh something
that made their plan look credible it
would help reassure the markets but
Mike's especially I'm afraid is it's
because of their Reckless approach so
they don't want anybody to see it you
say you're working across parties to try
to get the gov government to come
forward with this obr report what about
talking to Tory MPS are you talking to
them about that are you talking to them
about scrapping certain tax cuts
well I I'm not privy to any discussions
that have gone on with with conservative
back benches but I'm not surprised
really to read the reports that we have
seen about this because what the
government is doing is focusing on
taking away the 45 Pence top rate of
income tax benefiting a very small
number of people on the very highest
incomes they're taking away the cap on
Bankers bonuses whilst it's working
people who are paying the price so I'm
not surprised that there are uh MPS who
may be wishing to speak even from the
government benches on this because what
the government has done is by
prioritizing that tiny group of very
wealthy people and Wealthy companies
trying to rely on failed trickle-down
economics we know that millions of
families across the country will be
paying the price for it they should
actually change course and come back to
Parliament in fact